very weird stuff is going on like the
internet died I had to reconnect
doorbell just rang no one was at the
door but at least I have a good position
let's develop the fukes eeeh hello San
Diego hello X 159 welcome back uh Queen
85 check wins a piece the goal is to get
this game over with as quickly as
possible and then move on to the next
game pretty low quality game so far
slow-motion replay and give flight wants
to he should play like c3 after c5 we'll
take the bishop he's just not developing
anything Bishop b4 check looks
attractive tick
your house is officially haunted yeah
well that's why my dog is around to try
and scare away any ghosts oh yeah we're
gonna take the bishop and then if Queens
you - I've night see - King f1 I'm sure
I have something if king d1 I have rook
to e8 here microwave oven can cause
internet to fail really be delivery
sales or church group yeah but at 7:00
p.m.
like usually like we've been getting
like politician or political campaign
like people but usually not this late
hey I broke into the top thousand over
2300 people playing wait is Lee Lee
chess is detecting my stream hopefully
or maybe they aren't join the game wait
what's going on
why is everyone visiting okay well
desert to I guess if we both berserk it
still counts for classical chess which
is nice because my classical rating is
still provisional I'll play c5 this game
and we'll go into some Sicilian it says
I'm streaming but there's the same
streaming the tournament oh it does cool
okay II five
not a great move it over extends I'm
gonna play a six and just go for a d5
like usually white should not develop a
bishop so early to de-seed for because
it just gets kicked around and if he
moves back to b3 that would be ideal
there should be two probably the best
move and I'm gonna try and be aggressive
this game like I will go for some King
side attack if he lets me
d for interesting just gonna develop you
get a chance to play semi Slav in your
games is that an opening request because
I would play semi Slav semi slot used to
be one of the main lines in my repertory
against e4 I don't think I play that
recently though but I would play it if
given the chance and hello 1 a.m. that 1
a.m. thanks for following I'm gonna
continue developing but what do I wanted
to develop first cuz Queen b6 runs into
Bishop b3 I have to figure out how to
develop the kingside effectively I'm
gonna play 97 this is a terrible bug
house and crazy house move
if White has a knight to place on d6 but
as far as a chest move goes I think it's
okay
bring the Knight to g6 lots of people in
the chat microwaves don't emit signals
that far away even if they're in the
same room that was a hard sentence to
read yeah I don't think the microwave is
causing issues it's pretty far away from
the router h3 I don't understand it's
kind of a random move
but what does WAC do here like I wanna I
want to attack but probably first I have
to develop and go start with Queen c7
because I want to play d6 get the pawn
away from me five and then once the
position opens up and I can attack hello
Sir John oh nine sent a message on me
chess I get messages or I get like five
to ten messages every day on me chess
and it's hard to keep up with all of
them but I do I do my best for a smile
into all of them but sometimes it can
take up to a week because it's just I
mean they keep coming and coming so
usually I reserve like a few hours per
week just to go through all of them and
respond to everything it's one of the
one of the challenges being popular
online okay let's take the pawn first
and then I'll play g6 don't play semi
Slav against chest to Magus okay
interesting advice but that sounds like
a challenge like if I can play semi Slav
and beat him and it's a huge
accomplishment
can you try you to win using the
Scandinavian you should have told me
that before I played this the ceiling in
this game but if I'm black again and I
play against efore I'll place unit
Scandinavian so I think my black
repertory is not set for tonight
neither Scandinavian or semi Slav now
this position is looking pretty good
because I'm putting a pawn all right one
upon and I'll blacks just sub-material
and now this bishop super happy this is
what I was kind of waiting for long open
diagonal first time on the stream hello
why woke definitely a new viewer
thanks for joining all the northern and
eastern european openings semi Slav yeah
kind of Slavic Scandinavian style I was
in that area of the world over the
summer went to Latvia that's part of
Scandinavia right I think so
ok I'm gonna take with Queen could take
the other night - I'll take with Queen
this night's attack twice it probably
has to move unless he wants to play f3
but been flying gold would not approve
or unless he wants to just get me in the
night that's nice I think rookie one I
can play at five I also have Bishop d6
here I mean some calculation required I
also have rep ta here so a few candidate
moves a Bishop d6 Ricky for Queen h2
King a flowing Queen each one teeny -
Queen take G - mmm let's not go into
that rook - Yates I don't want to
calculate let's just play out five my
bishop is safely guarded by the pawn if
he plays that three then I have some
like Queen check or even Bishop c5 check
and rook ta is coming lots of moves are
coming rook da Bishop d6 or Bishop c5
it's nice being off a piece have you
ever played fins on me chess I don't
think I have feel like I would remember
I play them on chefs calm Queen C -
interesting he's building a pressure
he has future ideas of 26 which I
probably don't want to have happen
and if I take on g3 he has Queen c6
which would be very bad so I'm still
looking at Bishop d6 he takes on
euphoric windage to King f1 mmm he's
also threatening to take on you for and
just like trying to get compensation so
it's a little bit annoying I'm
considering Queen c5 the Queen c5 Bishop
to g4 pawn to e4 Quinta he for her we
don't trade Queens
I could play Bishop d6 he takes on you
for and just take back and queen c6 king
f7
I mean it's winning in many lines I'm
just trying to find the cleanest way to
win I think I'll start with Bishop d6
and just hold on to the extra piece oh
man I missed a lull of comments the
Budapest says the Fuchs eeeh at what
level do you think the Bangko starts to
become less sound isn't the bingo
refuted maybe not too many people know
the refutation I thought there's a line
where white play is 84 on move 12 so
whatever level people start playing 12 a
4 you should stop playing the Bangko as
I remember like deck maybe four or five
years ago I think it was still somewhat
played at high levels but then like this
12 a four line became really trendy and
I Benko just disappeared I think it's in
the line where white plays like efore
and then trades on f1 like king take f1
g3p me too and then later place 84 we
can take a look at that maybe a bit
later for any d4 players out there and
thanks for the cheer San Diego 25 bits
the motivation to to keep the string
going
okay let's castle get the King save up a
piece
I enjoyed Riga yeah Riga is very nice I
was in Riga for two weeks back in May
and June
very nice city but most people there
like most local people don't speak
English so language was a bit difficult
okay so he wins e4 we're keeping Queens
on the board I'll play Queen f5
I've Tuesday target h3s hanging there's
a pin life is good
maybe even if it should take g3 coming
I'm already getting challenges I don't
know if all accept challenges but I
might I don't know there's only 15
minutes left in this tournament it's
probably only time for like maximum
three more games but like one game could
theoretically take over 40 50 minutes
it's a nature of classical chess almost
everyone I play plays the Scandinavian
wrong interesting skin the avians are
difficult opening to play I forgot I'm
not attacking f2 because there's a queen
on c2 but I can play Queen f3 here I
just want to meet quickly Queen f3
yeah Queen us face good double threat of
green tape h3 and also my h4 o
Scandinavian is only Denmark Norway
Sweden Oh Nordic countries are Finland
and Iceland Latvia I didn't know that
and then there's a baltic region so oh
he stopped both threats
can i play Queen I for Queen f4 is OK
game of cat and mouse I attack him he
attacks me I want to play Queen h2 here
I have no fear of discoveries against
the Queen you might play rook g3 or that
but now I have this and good things
should happen I'm looking for a force
mate I know I can win the Queen by force
King f1 Queen h1 Keaney 2 row take F 2
that's probably good enough
if you didn't follow that line it's
about to happen I can actually cream
over to deaf too but yeah let's do it
now queen h2 I probably don't want to
cream them see my plate King d3 yeah
but now we can and can take the Queen
maybe there's a quicker mate like Queen
d5 I start with the king is running if
King c3 I've rook c8 mates if King III
okay Roxy it mates nice well that was a
feel good name what did you do wrong oh
yeah he played Bishop c4 and then he
played me five not a good combination of
moves like both these moves don't
usually make too much sense in Sicilian
okay back to tournaments so I'm taking
some opening requests I'm pretty sure
I'll be white next game so any opening
requests we have about 25 seconds let me
know Danish gambit the fukes eeeh okay
I'll play E for if the guy doesn't play
e5 I'll still take opening requests oh
he's playing French normally okay I'll
just play the on I'll play what I always
play against the French this two Knights
attack fun it's a fun variation it's
weaker players his fins John Bartholomew
yes he is no game found between me and
fins oh that's too bad
I actually the the first time I
encountered fins was in real life we
played in Washington Square Park and it
was I think it was maybe a year or two
before he actually started his YouTube
channel I had no idea who he was was
before before the fame and glory
I forget what happened in that game we
weren't playing for money so I don't
even count your c5 too often but it's a
playable note the issue for black is
after d4 there's going to be an IQ P and
it becomes a very positional game
Queen's Gambit drop King's gambit c4
emojis only be for wait II for and then
c4 that's really weakening to the d4
square trying to imagine efore followed
by c4 is good if your opponent's plane
caro-kann but otherwise when you combine
the two moves I don't think it should
make sense here the strategy for white
is just to get the rope to the e-file
and I'm pretty sure I can castle there's
only one issue if I Castle he can take
on d4 and if I take with Queen he can
take on f3 it looks Pleasant little for
whites throw in your key one my goal for
the next like several moves is to keep
the black King in the center like he
hasn't touched his King side pieces and
if I can make it so he can't castle then
good things will happen for whites so
there's all these fans like rook you
want me be even Queen e2 and there's
still pressure in the center like this
pressure on both g5 n c5 and the pin
against a knight so he's going for this
line which not a hundred percent sure
about I play rook e1 Bishop e7 take on
d4 he for playing that of six
rookie one vision t7 some funny line
where I sack my queen like rook e1
Bishop e7 might take t4 it should take
t1 Knight takes c6 well but he can take
him King f8 okay so Queens 84 Bishop
take f3 pawn take f3 I'm threatening d5
I have the double pawns so you're
probably friend I have six this looks
good
like I accept the double pawns i crusher
the e-file I create some battery with
the Queen and rook let's do it
I just read the comment from expert I
was avoiding looking of the chat there a
Queenie one then they take t4 I didn't
even consider maybe that was that was
somewhat reasonable I didn't consider it
because my rook wants to go to you why
not the Queen okay I'm gonna take back I
know this looks ugly but sometimes when
you have double pawns it's okay if your
pieces are active
let's talk about mouse and trackpad Eric
if I had a mouse I'd be crushing you
right now and some bullet I don't think
that's true because right now I'm
playing the classical arena I probably
wouldn't accept any bullet challenges
and I still haven't ordered a mouse on
Amazon so I'm looking to get like a
webcam on Amazon I want to order them
together and it's just it's delaying it
even further but hopefully within a few
days I will have a mouse and a new
webcam and life will be even better
but for now I'm sticking with the
trackpad which which i think is
manageable for classful chess I have to
keep these opening suggestions in mind
I'll try and play as many openings as
people suggest today um okay he just
moved Knight of 6 so the planets will
play rook e1 Bishop e7 Queen e5 and then
there's some line where like you could
try and castle but then I take on c6 B
takes c6 I take on e7 if he plays rook
e8 I take the Queen and then he just
can't untangle that easily
rookie one there's also moves like Queen
c5 which could be playable yeah let's
start with rookie 1 then I'm gonna
decide between Queen e5 and Queen c5
Queen c5 looks more attractive just
visually because I attack the knight and
it might force him to like rook c8
and then I played Bishop g5 and there's
so much pressure because like this night
the other night the bishop on e7 pawn on
e5 everything's gonna be attacked at
least a few times so this looks nice and
hello to reboot all I could play the
Alekhine but someone else said to play
the Scandinavian so and Scandinavian is
just more exciting than Alekhine but
we'll see what happens I guess I could
combine the two openings ie for d5
you take t5 906 and then it's a
Portuguese variation so reboot all is
for Queen's Gambit as well from the
white side or yeah probably from the
white side I have to plug in my laptop
before it dies it's overheating pretty
badly right now I put a sound filter on
OBS so when my laptop overheats it
shouldn't make too much noise so
hopefully that's in effect right now
team scandi yeah I play the Scandinavian
different than John Bartholomew
what is King d7 like are you for real
what is this move it was that a mouse
lip or he actually intended to play King
d7 very unexpected
this is gonna be good for whites and now
it's time to calculate it I mean I can
take on d5 might take T 5.85 King c8 I
take on c6 I mean I don't think there's
too much to calculate the defiles
opening and the this night is still pin
so there's no there's no 1984 oh he
might play King see AIDS King c8 after
night tape d5 okay let's calculate night
85 King C is attacking my queen if I
take on c6 he takes back the pawn my
Knights pinned and I don't have Queen g4
okay there's some point so Knight 85
King see it's maybe just c4 weight c4
hangs the Queen
I take t5 King c8 bishop takes c6 pawn
takes c6 this is weird I know it's good
for whites if this is good for a Bock I
quit chess but this is definitely good
for whites Bishop g5 maybe mr. g5 King
see aids we trade some I don't know
because there are issues for light
surprising move well it's equal material
his Kings on d7 maybe I shouldn't win a
pawn maybe I should do something else I
take on c6 immediately that doesn't make
any sense
I have some other idea to play Bishop f4
it's clear he wants to play king CA so
let's imagine there's about four king c8
and then either Queen a4 or take on c6
and then Queen a4 and whites just fully
developed two bishops c6 is targeted if
you place Queen b6 that's a move then
maybe something like rook t1 or I play
Queen a4 immediately in preventing seats
it's weird cuz I don't see anything like
too convincing and I really wanted to
take on g5
okay let's reexamine might take G five
Kings see it there's a pin and he wants
to take back his two threats I take on
c6 he takes back and I play maybe Queen
c4 that could be interesting it's a
piece AK Queen c4
so imagine Queen take d5 Queen a6 check
King C seven digit f4 and his Bishop d6
yeah I don't want to risk that so Bishop
f4 is while I'm leaning towards here
Bishop f4 King c8 I maybe quit a4 and
keep all the tension preparing work D 1
if he plays Queen b6 maybe just rip d1
and my pieces are better than his PC my
pieces are better than his pieces should
be good for whites I wasn't looking at
the chat but hello Tony and he is a
1,300 player I might be overthinking it
but like I want to play good quality
chess it's a nature of classical chess
and I didn't mention this but I'm
playing and then over the board
tournament tomorrow so this is sort of a
warm-up and I think tomorrow I'll be
playing some slightly weaker players and
one of the danger things for me when I'm
playing player is much below meaning
sometimes I get too comfortable and
that's where I mess up so I'm trying to
get in the mindset where I take every
position seriously
you place Kings see it's okay I'm gonna
play 24 and now there's threats of just
taking and then Queenie six I'm
expecting him to do this oh but maybe
then I had this JCS says might 85 works
I want to go into the into that line
after the game because it felt like it
should work I didn't see how it worked
Bishop f4 he can't be too safe with the
King on c8
yeah this King is just like a long-term
weakness and because the Kings on CA
does Rick is stuck forever what did I
just do oh I did send them I want some
money
and black just has lack of coordination
Queen g7 makes me happy it's now
probably just rip d1 just build up
pressure Queen h3 ideas aren't too scary
okay 51
I don't know what the thread is I'm sure
there's some threat maybe 95 I take T 5
and then C 4 or even might take D 5 1985
rooked 85 Queen take D 5 rook e8 check
could be plausible
he plays Bishop d6 but now d5 is just
hanging some knight 85 if he takes on
that for I denied b6 check and that wins
something that wins with me if I take d5
Knight 85 rooked 85 his Bishop is pinned
and attacked twice and why it's just
winning okay definitely didn't work the
knight and the Queen are attacked and
there's no there's no chicks or no
checks probably no checks yeah I mean
the way that line could work is if like
white sacks apiece and there's just
massive compensation and that's what I
want to look into because I've realized
like doing a lot of these like games
against weaker players
I have opportunities to sack material
but sometimes I play too cautiously and
that may have happened in this game that
I don't know at least White's winning
might be six as a major threat black's
pieces are just falling apart
so I'll probably just have one more game
after this and then in half hour like
when the tournament ends I'll have to
figure out what to do this will probably
be a shorter stream than normal because
I want to sleep before tomorrow but if
anyone wants to play me or people have
suggestions or questions just let me
know know in the chat especially like
opening questions
I'm usually happy to answer especially
yesterday yesterday I was giving away so
many opening secrets few secret
novelties but if I'm not gonna use them
in tournaments I might as well give them
away for free
so this guy's suffering what's what's
happening with him maybe realizing his
position is uh it's very very bad the
cyma lore viewer attorney I haven't done
a viewer tournament in a while I could
do that but that would require like
playing many more games hmm let me see
the settings okay go take on d5 I don't
see any resources for black here so many
pins
and both Brooks are just out of play Oh
a thematic tournament but I don't like
forcing people to play like certain
openings I guess maybe it would be
interesting we'll see I don't know I'll
keep thinking I'll probably just do
viewer challenges already have two
challenges Eve eh I think I played
yesterday I'm King AJ interesting from
the USA Thank You cloud SATs for
following some interesting combination
of words but yeah going back just for
people who are just joining us this is a
great line against the French the two
Knights attack less common so many ways
for black to go wrong this game after d4
like it's already difficult for black
because he has to develop the Kings side
but he just developed too slowly like he
developed the Queen side first and that
his King had issues especially after
King d7 but there's a d7 I mean that
also looks pretty scary so I guess this
could still take like 12 more minutes to
finish you plays rookie it's okay I
guess that's a reasonable try i take he
takes i take on d6 you have one check
what did I just do it's not not slip
okay we'll take care
and sometimes when you're all material
you just want to trade everything this
situation with some material I don't
want to trade I just want to like attack
and like made him as quickly as possible
which shouldn't be too hard to do unless
he uses all this time desert budge is
asking can you play a game with English
opening if I'm white again I'll play
English so I think a few people have
asked for English one person asks for
Grob but we'll stay somewhat polite Alec
I know I'll try and play at some points
but sky Navion comes before Alekhine
saxy 90 i played 12 games over the board
got away 6 out of 12 points 5 white wins
2 back draws ouch
yeah black openings can be tricky
especially if you're complaining good
players like they'll try and punish you
this is double check this is winning
like all of black's pieces or just
meaning oh it's made them to king g7
Queen d4 teeny 726 meter okay
that works out nicely I mean when you're
studying openings as black you want a
response to e4 a response to d4 and then
some way to deal with all these like
ready English kind of move order tricks
maybe it's not Nathan - it's a maiden 3
I shouldn't be thinking here but okay
let's start with Bishop C weights Bishop
c7 q c8 Queen g4 okay Queen d4 if he
plays Queen d7 I'll play rook d6 I'll be
good enough
Oh even better if he plays Queen d7 I
play rook c8 tact eCos rook takes you
eight nine Queen take d7 ooh crew 64 in
the chats this is nice and cream of this
way he could play key me seven ornaments
okay good game
real quick what was stock cash wanting
to do after a team d7 cuz I mean I
wanted to take on d5 but King c8 I
didn't see what to do here I like I
didn't even know if likes better here
that was a big problem because the
Queen's attacked and this is attacked
and if I take he takes mmm-hmm I'm sure
there's some comp oh yeah I was thinking
Queen a4 do I just start the game I just
started a game okay well place candy
let's run sock fish please don't flag me
for cheating I'm just wanting to see the
opening okay White's still better there
was my take t5 the best move it was okay
interesting
okay we'll go back to the game that I
just started and we'll play Med of six
because I'm pretty sure I'm pretty
shortly chess has some detection if
you're like using stock fish during a
game
it might flag you but for now I think
I'm safe Bishop e5 to check I forget
what to play I think Bishop d7 is a
mainline I was looking at the saw a day
from the white side and then something
like beef
and Bishop b3 yeah someone actually
played this against me about your day
and I have a really cool like almost
novelty in this position which I showed
like maybe two or three streams ago
where black plays a five and then white
can respond with a 4b take a foregrip
take a four and it's actually a very
powerful opening from whites exchange
sack but whites like almost winning so I
think the alternative here is Bishop g4
most likely he'll play f3 and then I'll
play Bishop c8 pretty sure how that
that's how it goes
G moves has anyone played with engine PI
on d GT I have no idea what he means by
that okay we go back to CA the spawns
attacked if he plays this I think I have
before he plays Queen e2 I'm scared that
like he's booked up but okay his ratings
aren't too scary um probably a six I'm
very scared that he's booked up because
this is the type of line that you hope
you'd play if you're if you're you know
what you're doing is c4 and he's playing
very quickly but I think I can take if I
take zinc with bishop or queen but
either way I played Bishop e7
maybe he'll defend the D pawn temper
early but there should be Bishop d7 and
then Knight to b6 maneuvers
you could play Knight c3 here or Bishop
a4 Chuck but 97 is coming next crew 6
before asking how long is this
tournament this tournament is like 9 or
10 hours it's ridiculous
I mean it's 20 plus 10 I think they only
run this tournament every month I just
hang d6 because this is a big threat
weights I have to think because I
honestly didn't see that move I should
have I should have been warned Queen and
Bishop battery well this was
embarrassing if I'm losing the game like
right away
I think there's resources to survive
Bishop d5 was the first move that comes
to mind you could take on c7 that's a
big problem
cuz when he takes on c7 he
he probably has a good position vision
he thought this would take see Simon
Bishop takes you for weight he just wins
a piece that's bad his hero here I have
not seen hero I'm sure he exists
somewhere on this planet I mean the only
other reasonable try I see is Queens 86
Queen take up 17 d8 and maybe there's
some accidental compensation lacks time
upon but white scheme is slightly unsafe
- I just want to get out of his prep
yeah I guess I'll go for it
dollop on I mean it could be much worse
man thought my last opponent was bad for
moving his King to the D file so early
but now I know what it feels like but
okay this King is somewhat safe knight
c6 is coming
thank you raw red Hart Lane for the
follow yet clearly wants a Queen trade
which I might have to allow I don't
think I would be too upset about the
Queen trade because black is developing
quickly I'll do this maybe open the
e-file
ninety-four ideas there's Knight c3 well
now Knight d4 is very tempting
it's my Knight d4 just a good square
there's no white pollen that can attack
it I'm actually a bit torn here I tell
all my students like take towards the
center most often I'm more inclined to
take with the e pod because I want to I
want the e-file to open I take with a C
pawn and the C file opens and in
decision I think it's just like an
intuition thing there's nothing to
calculate let's stick with the e pawn
okay down the pod against a random 1350
player is actually 1833 provisional
Bishop a4 is somewhat logical avoiding
the trade in controlling he eights I
might go for like there's tricks with
like accessing the t3 square
there's also 94 possibilities but I want
to develop the bishop as well so I'm
debating here between g6 and Bishop g7
or if I play 95 right away there is my
take d5 and when we trade
okay I'm gonna play Bishop g7 or g6
Bishop g7 maybe c6 d 5 rook e8 it's
going for some active play and he's
playing very well so far I'm talk--i
ponent there's no sacking on a3 and
positions like this [ __ ] doesn't want to
trade I might be forced to trade with
like I don't know so I don't want to
retreat 92 is a good move if I play 96
planning then c5 he plays d4 this is
very difficult probably has to trade and
just be down upon I could consider c5
but accepting the double pawns can be
good
okay let's trade chat can I was saying
95 question mark but I forget what
moment that was wait did I mess up at
some point but 95 was also said by crew
64 when do I have 95 I'm gonna play
Bishop g7 here and then go back Oh 95 in
this position but then Oh take Queen
take aha I didn't mean I did not even
consider 95 guess I forgot it was
defending c7 but he has Knight c3
Misun maybe c6
I have to look back at the opening
because already it's like it's very
difficult position with the plan is to
play like c6 85 Bishop a6 at some point
d5 rook e8 c but whites moves are coming
quickly too but also play Bishop d5 and
then c6 suspicious is so annoying anger
issues c6 this is passive move Knight d7
like 97 96 doesn't look great I could be
more active with 95 495 Jun 95 looks
like the best I'm a practical move
potentially preparing Knight b6 I want
to chase the bishop away to get the e8
Square for the rook and then then we'll
see what happens and here are clicking
see it he's playing so quickly like he
has more he's playing every move like
within like five seconds I think it's
difficult
so Knight b6 trying off the pace or I
play h6 let's throw in h6 see where the
bishop goes
because the square is weak so Bishop t2
like every yeah every movies gaining
time so hopefully it gets to a point
where he messes up somewhat to
preferable I'm looking at 96 Bishop III
rookies I hit the night and it's
defending d4 but his rookie one calais
Knight b6 anyway this is if he plays
Bishop b3 I have my play Bishop to d5
and just trade because this is a
long-term weakness Bishop c2 I kind of
figure out of that which is probably a
good move so rook e8 rook e1 I don't
really want to play g5 but I might have
to g5 runs into h4 stuff
okay let's start with rook e8 if he
plays rook e1 then h4 is less scary if
he moves the knight I could maybe win
the pod oh so we're going into the sign
he's not scared of Bishop 284 because
bishop take g6 aha what does this guy is
it's raining he plays rapid and blitz
only 1,500 and blitz okay it gives me
some hope but in this position like he's
just completely out playing me in g5 if
I play G fight he is 9.5
if I take on d4 or he could take on each
six first and blacks losing another pawn
which is not fun maybe the Scandinavian
was just a bad opening choice which is
very unfortunate as players usually
don't don't I'll play me like this let's
say Knight c4 take mm-hmm nothing looks
attractive take take
I'm sort of beginning to accept the fact
that I'm losing both pawns on the
kingside I have to generate some counter
play on the queenside the problem is he
keeps initiative like when he takes this
pawn he would attack my Bishop on d4
when it's a spawn he attacks my work on
e8 and I mean I want to play g5 but I
don't want to allow nights at 5 what to
do I could just cry for the next 10
minutes oh wait a minute
is that have some purpose if I take on
d4 he takes on 8 6 7 I played rook eight
shades and I counter-attack and if he
takes one before I take on each six at
least muddies the waters he's rich e4 in
the very end this will probably winds up
on at least I'm giving them a choice
like if I take on d4 he has to choose
which one to take maybe induce the
mistake I'm also like I'm also getting
in Queen side majority which gives me
some hope but not too much hope did you
find that tactic or tactic oh he's
talking to Braden
oh hello breathing 12 hours until the
candidates we need a a moobot command
fairly a candidates countdown in
deduction likes my commentary but
probably not my play because this is
difficult I have another idea which
doesn't work at all but I wanted to like
meets Bishop to e6 with rookie six but
then there's Bishop f5 that's really
annoying and he explained quickly it's
also very annoying
so what do i do I want to keep users on
the board maybe there's some kind of
Bishop D for Bishop take Jesus my saying
Bishop e5 bishop take g6 rookie Bishop
f5 came here and there's some pressure
along the file there's Mike c4
possibilities that's the best I can ask
for it's not fun but not everything in
life is fun let's do it at least this is
one good piece uh I have a 19-12 rating
because I'm provisional if you see the
question mark next to this it doesn't
mean that I'm a fake I am it just means
I haven't played enough classical games
I think this is maybe my Sixers sat in a
classical game ever and he also has a
fake rating or fake classical rating but
he's playing well beyond 1800 so let's
do this trying something he owe me H
kind of odd position odd is probably a
very polite way of putting it
it's probably just a bad position this
came from the scam Union this is Duffy I
want to analyze afterwards because I
play a similar line from the white side
and I want to see if it's just a
refutation so King v8 down to pons
I'm threatening something on g3 and he's
taking his time this game is not going
to finish before the tournament ends
so maybe that's a good thing once it
won't dirty my my tournament performance
even though I just joined the tournament
I'm probably in like I even know what
place I mean does it say oh it says oh
I'm in 429 place interesting and he's in
he's not even in the top thousand that's
so said there should be four I didn't
even see that that's a good move defends
stuff on g3 but now it's time for
counter play like finally I haven't
moved where I can make some initiative
happen maybe nine eight four there's
also Bishop to d5 so if I play there's a
d5 if you plays King be woman oh I have
a trick I want to say the trick because
you might be watching I want to start
with 94 I actually don't know if the
trick works but it might work so let's
start with this
Bradon asking am i rooting for anyone
wait what Oh in the candidates obviously
the American players Wesley or Fabiano
probably Fabiano but it would be cool to
see an American and the World
Championships because it hasn't happened
recently at all and I'll probably be
attending the World Championships in
November in London so it would be cool
to see someone who actually know in in
person so I was hoping for Ricky to I
actually don't know if the trick works
but the ideal is to play rook h8 here
and there's pressure along an h-file
there's also threats of actually I don't
know what I'm saying
if the bishop somehow moves off this
diagonal there'd be ideas of this path
for so let's play rook h8 might be
turning the tables here I mean the whole
point was to distract this rook from
defending each one by targeting b2 not
because as h1 work isn't defended I can
take on g3 and that's a free piece I
hope he resigns he doesn't even wait for
me to take wow I mean at least fight on
so I was wrong the game finished before
the tournament ends that was nice
I don't know if I deserve to win that
game but at least I kept fighting
let's pause no I wanted to pause I
didn't want to keep going I wanted to
see that game but I guess where we're
continuing all beserk this game I was a
millisecond too late to click the pause
button
let's play aggressively wait what's this
guy is reading okay yeah let's fight
aggressively yeah fast poof's and fast
resignation I'll play Budapest this game
fun opening Oh
someone said semi Slav well too bad I
forgot played Bishop c5 the move to hope
for in this position is Bishop g5 so one
of the most natural-looking blunders
white can play but we'll see what
happens
9 of 3 makes sense um one thing about
the Budapest it's usually just bad to
decline it like this is already pretty
comfortable for black but I do have to
prove it lets castle
well is this Budapest this is Budapest
declined with d5 on move 3 he plays h3 I
might have to slow play this position
like night BB 7 and then do some Spanish
type maneuvers rook e8 well he wants to
play 94 hmm but 94 this should be 4
check wait a minute what's going on
don't click that link in the chat block
yeah
wait how do I twitches being annoying
ban user sorry
sometimes these twitch BOTS share
malware links you have to avoid them
okay I have a funny move here I play e4
and the other way with it I think I can
let's have some fun
looks like a fun move JCS is asking what
does black do after accepting or after
white accepts a gambit detainee 594
vision f4 I would play either Bishop b4
check or knight c6 and it leads to it
leads to an interesting position there
white can't always hold on to the pawn
so Knight e4 somewhat expected yeah I
don't know if I should have lady for it
and now it's slightly overextended but I
can probably continue like rookie aides
reinforced upon and now he has no time
for a 94 and this pawn could be strong
if it's reinforced he wants to attack it
then he just lost a piece Wow everyone's
hanging pieces today my most games
determined by blunders 94 was not
possible yeah and I take me for I forgot
to mention this trick if if might take
me for I would take back sacrificing the
Queen and then made him on f2 so he's
playing on I really want to take on f2 I
don't think it does anything
I'm just Bishop c5 standard move
yeah Bishop c5 or III sometimes if you
can play e3 it could be good but not
here
so box with stuff apiece nothing more to
talk about
I should mention that a key for probably
runs into wrote a key for our wait 1984
runs in tonight a key for even the same
meeting I've use let's throw in h6 I
make the bishop retreats now if you
plays Bishop each for I might just buy
g5 yeah why not I mean black swap apiece
White has no attack there's all this
debate like when you should play g5 when
you're already castled and usually if
your opponent doesn't have an attack
then it's okay to play g5 because here
black just has more pieces I may have
forgotten about a for not being defended
but if he takes it I would take he would
take there's Bishop b4 check at the very
least so I am Rosen auto mod needs a mod
okay although mod will finally have a
new mod well it's not accidentally ban
kiyomi okay that's a mod icon
congratulations Kimmy is now the auto
mod mod or just a mod in general I
should have probably given that earlier
congratulations on the less
yeah this should be over very shortly I
mean kini too is pretty much forced oh
and there's actually a special room just
for moderators which I forgot about well
I think anyone uses that huh okay uh
okay Keaney - I mean I'm up at peace
White's King is on E - should not last
much longer maybe just window six
threatening some Bishop f5 I mean I'm
looking for mates cuz like the King has
no legal moves here and it's usually a
good time to look for ways to just win
the game there's some really funny idea
like let's imagine my paws on g4 and his
queens on g4 I could play Queen f3 sac
the Queen and then G take out three
would-be mates I don't know if there's a
way to actually make that happen though
especially after a three Bishop f5 Queen
d4 Bishop c5 Queen c3 and maybe just a
five and I'm happy okay
good enough
I was making tea man making tea during
one of the most monumental times in your
life okay Bishop c5 queen c3 I think is
forced maybe Bishop efore looks
reasonable a large majority of the games
I played and at least in this tournament
like my opponents haven't castled or at
least one side hasn't castled guess that
last game I didn't castle but it's used
to be a recurring theme people not
castling and developing quickly enough
bad things usually happen but that's the
case or good things depending on side
you are so Bishop f3 is probably a
threat but he makes a counter threat so
if I play there's a bath free GTA got to
be a queen take off a teeny one Bishop
still hanging oh he wants to trap the
bishop - maybe I got too relaxed that's
not good
okay it should still be good for luck
the problem is the Bishop's getting
trapped what to do I could sack back the
piece or in this case blunder back the
piece okay if he wants to win the bishop
I can at least open the see file like
after c5 I'll do something he'll take I
take and then they see file action that
should be good enough any other tricks
his Queen's not defended I want this
came to be on anyone so I could play
Knight of three so maybe I played Bishop
g6 he takes the ship h5 at 3 now that's
yeah that's more than good so let's just
start with Bishop h5 because I think
it's just winning material back I'll at
least be up to exchange maybe more oh
yeah after a three I take and I'll be
hitting the King fish of the rook okay
life is good life is very good Wow over
a hundred people watching witnessing
this masterpiece uh-oh I want to take my
bishop but it won't let me
okay so I'll just take the rook is there
something better
I'll just take the room
yeah I'll take that [ __ ] fun and see
file can be very valuable so material oh
I have an extra pawn - and the exchange
and the C file slide time deficits but
okay his King is still the targets he
wants to play rook F flowing let's just
scoot over ideas of Queenie for with the
triple fork a lot of undefended pawns
also some ideas of Knight e3 let's start
with Queen d5 if he can defend all three
pawns in one move I'd be really
impressive but I don't think it's
possible
mmm okay I'll take with Brooke and it's
just a mating attack can take on d5
first Queen and two rooks
our major pieces if he need to Rick see
to Keaney one and take on you three can
probably pre move rook c1 water that's
more water ooh that was mates okay well
good
not a bad finish to the tournament not
the most impressive game by whites with
hanging the knight on d4 I do want to go
back to the previous game I played
against a guy who was very booked up if
he box with Bishop I mean I pre moved
rook c1 and then he would be forced to
take and it's not immediately mate but I
would just be on the Queen so anyway
let's go back to tournament and
congratulations to chest to Magus strong
performance earning the shield and how
do I get to my games
wait what place do I finish I'm a 318 ok
not bad how those I love over 2,000
players I remember like the time Lee
chest broke 2,000 players for a
tournament it was like a huge monumental
achievement because it was like the
biggest ever online tournament but now
it's just normal so that's cool I know I
have pending challenges I just want to
go to the game I played in the second to
last this is second to last round or
whatever because I was in a really bad
position and then stuff happened
analysis forward so how far did we
follow theory oh and I showed this other
day I might as well show it again but if
you're playing from the light side
against this
there's a really cool idea a5 a4 pawn to
a4 rook take a four so now the novelty
but a very nice exchange sack after a
bishop take a for Bishop taking 497 a
white style material but White has a
very strong initiative after night of 3G
695 d5 and black won't be able to castle
because knight c6 happens and after
Queen c8 what can just play see for an
e7 needs to be defended Queen e2 is
coming so this is a really nice line to
know in the Scandinavian from whites and
that's why I didn't play a 5 I instead
played thank you for the follow X 24
hour VR I played the other main move
Bishop to g4 f3 Bishop CA and then I
think after after Queen e2 I was just
out of breath because I haven't studied
the Sun too deeply we need to his second
most popular move I played a six and he
played c4 he takes c4 Queen Jake c4 I
just didn't see d6 coming it seems like
such an obvious tactic but I just missed
it and white scores variable there so
after Queen e2
I mean a6 is most played Queen okay c4
this is probably a position for stock
fish like stock fish will handle this
better than opening book I'm just
curious any like masters games in this
Queen e2 a6
see for only one game c6 I didn't even
consider
okay let's use stockfish whoa
after say after Queen e2 Oh after Queen
e2 a6 obviously c4 c6 interesting
accepting basically accepting the loss
of a pond and just trying to develop and
actually that's a really nice move like
the more I look at it because if contact
c6 Knight takes c6 and like 19 4 is
already coming this looks amazing for
black and applaud take b5 I assume we
take back well we play a take b5 ah so
you take t5 also possible this looks
more normal and this pawn that f3 that's
awkward for why it's vice of the D pawn
looks very pleasant for black and this
also looks fine keeping the tension what
happened in the game was after c4 I took
took and then e 6 or Bishop e7 and then
e 6 which I just didn't see coming and
then everyone in the chat was suggesting
Knight d5 but I wasn't looking at the
chat and 95 just didn't come to mind but
the line I played like it I think it was
still somewhat playable is the stream
lagging if the stream is lagging I'm
sorry but it could be your internet
connection
I might have to reduce a bit rates let
me know supreme horse - I don't think
anyone else mentioned there was lag so
like there's not but anyway black was
just worse here thanks for the follow
somebody and I can't pronounced Alec he
meek 86
my best but this was some nice
demonstration of some fighting chess
another follow hyper prior wait I might
like breaking a thousand followers and
go to my stream because we need some
celebration followers new tab I have to
do something special for a thousand
followers Oh 990 okay we need 10 more
followers I should probably keep track
of who's who the 1000th follower is uh
I'll see I might just not keep track but
I'll try and do something special I
don't know anyway what happened this
meaning light was just better until
white wasn't better like there's some
complications and he played really well
King bee
yeah just rook tea - I think there's a
plunger or was it not a blender wait
okay I'm hiding the notation and I'm
curious like what does white do here to
save the piece because if it says
White's better but how does he deal with
all this pressure on the h-file
oh and it says in the notation I just
glanced with notation night at five
which makes a lot of sense initially I
thought rook takes Bishop was somehow
working was just training this is just a
trade might still have two pawns okay
fair enough
Knights e4 question mark
Braden's getting the board mixed up
another follower comments with many S's
so we're up to nine hundred ninety one
and if I can count correctly oh yeah
let's move on I'll play some viewers I
don't know how long this will actually
last Matt Horwitz thanks for following
path to grandmaster that sounds like a
really familiar name from USA why do I
feel like I know that name but he wants
to play chess 960 John you can call me
Pat okay I might want to play some like
quicker games okay I'll play King AJ cuz
he was one of the first people to
challenge me it's just a one-minute game
we'll get this out of the way and then
I'll play I'll play some other people
okay let's play you for thank you epic
Apophis for the follow hey Knight c3
h4 I had this position or this exact
opening another day probably yesterday
where g5 is weak now it is hard to
adjust from slow chess to bullets
but I'm trying my best let's play
92-year accepting the double pawns and
then oh he might Castle queenside well
that losses f7 hopefully the bishop
doesn't get trapped win another poem
my bishop i-5 coming he's six Bishop h3
I don't know where the Kings should go
let's just castle can be one this looks
reasonable lights up white like two
pawns this pawns weak there's two
bishops up on time it's always good
night g4 I was a good move
taken Bishop e3 I don't know why he's
thinking but without a flag keep trading
push the H pawn keep pushing
make some lifts for the king or take a
free roof which is not actually free I
didn't see that queen will take a free
pawn trade Queens start pre moving so a
little bit of lag but he fight okay
good game another follow from school
tide thank you I'll take a moment to
respond to people in the chat
hello perpetual stalemates stream is
fine the chessboard movements looking
laggy yeah I guess one minute for some
reason when I play one minute it lags
Eric are you playing tomorrow and the
fisherman Morial yes I am are you
playing is a bigger question but I'm
planning to play if I can wake up and
not oversleep for some reason you
thought my last name was Hanson I'm not
sure whether to feel flattered or
offended but yeah maybe it's confusing
with multiple Eric's who stream I'm
gonna play evh because he's I think he's
only subscriber and this list of
challengers and he subscribed and
through bits and donated so he deserves
some love good luck and have fun
I apologize the fucsia for auto am I not
liking your name okay let's play I
forgot what I played against him let's
place the candy time three out of three
against him
nice we'll play the same line
it was probably watching earlier so
maybe like yardie knows what to do in
this line though we'll see it's weird
like isn't it there's a stream lagging
because I'm getting some like red dots a
Red Square thing I might just have to
use a bit rate okay we'll take on d5
hopefully it's not too bad it's way c6i
this is already like a comfortable kind
of strut up for it set up for a
throwback it's a bit choppy
yeah the bit rate is probably too high
[Music]
real quick I'm going to end the stream
change the bitrate and then return then
hopefully it's okay actually I'll do so
after this game about that because I
don't want to like break up the stream
and say like two separate videos with
what the game gets come up it could just
be their internet too which is probably
more likely I really want to play h5
here h5 is like somewhat disrespectful
because I only play it against low rated
players but I'm playing it anyway I
might be okay like if he takes there's
going to be a huge attack on the h-file
and if he doesn't take I just want to
continue doing stuff reducing the
quality event
let me try can I reduce a bit rate
during the stream settings output look
bitrate is at 4,000 let's make it at
2,000 hopefully that works I just
changed a bit rate like during the
stream and now it looks okay but let me
know I'm not h2 is a good move or is it
cuz he wants to win g4 is h5m
I mean h5 is a move but I don't know if
it's a good move attempted to play f5
here g3 also looks tempting let's play
f5 cuz those nights stuck I want to do
this and this next moves it's good now
okay yeah maybe 4,000 was too high let's
do this and this is a type of position
I'm happy like against a lower rated
player because it takes a lot of
precision to defend his white and I
think he's already given me some some
mating attack I think after a 5 he had
to play like d4 and cover at age 6
square yeah this is good to know so if
if the stream ever lags again I'll just
reduce a bit rate during stream and that
he resigns cuz I would take the Knights
a tough game evh real quick is for
future knowledge I'm pretty sure you can
just take the knight or take the bishop
and survive just in this position like
you have to see this threat and probably
just d4 Queen b6 g3 but I don't know
like I could still play Queen h5
and I mean White has to play accurately
maybe Kingi to Queen h5h one and weights
up the piece there is compensation
though let's go yeah let's just chest
let's check stock fish just to make sure
I didn't miss anything but what's better
here and if we go back you and further
to this position likes much better Oh a
95 95 is just yeah cuz you want to take
on g4 and Queen d6 I assume you take on
g4 Oh with the Queen oh you take with
Queen because queen ju v queen see a
meat that's dirty and the meanwhile you
just want to play another three defend
so i would have been in trouble if
ninety five happened but that's hard to
see that's kind of a stock fish type
move to find okay um we can move on what
did I want to do oh I already changed
the bit rates so maybe one more person
desert budge let's go 3-2 mmm another
somewhat low rated player will give them
a game good luck have fun
oh let's play Kings gambit I kind of
feel like it's an Bishop c4 and yeah
this is actually a fun line cuz Queen h4
it looks good for lack after a king f1 a
problem for black is neither 3d for both
come very quickly I play d4 right away
it's Judy for right away
Ling g4i avoid me
903 will come next and then f4 is
attacked this looks nice I think usually
with a slime block shouldn't play Queen
h4 and I think the main move the main
move after Bishop c4 is actually to play
d5 just take some opening knowledge good
9 f3 have six just gonna keep developing
like this looks really nice like 94 or
95 coming ie 5 coming at 4 still weak I
think the King's gambit is like under
valued at lower levels my lower rail
players will look at high rate of
players for openings but at any level I
think below like 1800 in Kings gambit
can be very effective because it's just
easier for white to play if you have
some knowledge I'm gonna play Bishop d3
here Bishop d3 also would like to keep
the bishop on c4 the move I wanted to
play is 92 but that runs into g5
[Music]
let's play Bishop d3 Queen h5 wait if we
niche five I win the pawn and if Queen
g4 okay this is gonna be very nice
h3 I just want to chase the Queen away
from defending the pawn like Queen g3 I
have 92 Queen h5 I can take on that for
what did I title this stream slow and
instructive
I apologize for playing a bollock game
and making the stream title somewhat
deceiving I did not intend to play
bullet today but I guess it has turned
into like a viewer challenge stream 92
Queen will move wait i trapped the Queen
I didn't even see that that was an
accidental Queen trap I was so excited
to win the pawn I didn't like didn't
even consider the Queen had no squares
that's a sign that I'm just getting
tired I have this might be my last game
assuming I can convert I lost the chat
for a moment slow and instructive
yada-yada viewers challenge oh can you
change the stream title with a command
because that would be cool
I'll look into that from for moobot also
let me know like if anyone has any
suggestions how to make the stream
better or like anything I can do in
general to make it a more enjoyable
experience I'm open to feedback let me
just finish this game or flag him my
plan is to do this and this and maybe
this gets some kind of mates the goal is
to check me at him before he Flags which
could be challenging but maybe possible
it's looking likely still a bit tricky
where's a mate oh that's a nice mates
queen take a five and then this then
this and then this
okay oh thanks for the follow racks ooh
did we hit 1000 refresh followers wait
what
followers we need four more followers to
get to 1000 maybe I won't end the stream
until there's four more followers but
that might incentivize people to
unfollow and I don't want that to happen
either I'm conflicted probably what I'll
do I'm very conflicted how many
challenges I have five pending
challenges I need subscribers dolphin
master I'm really tired and I have a
tournament tomorrow oh we have another
follower to 997
I kind of want to end it here I want to
end it with just below a thousand
followers end it with a beautiful
checkmate and then end it or start the
next stream by freaking a thousand
followers I think that would be nice
so thanks everyone for watching I'm
sorry for the people who are currently
challenging me you'll have to wait until
the future but I'll be back sometime in
the future probably not tomorrow but
probably sometime on Sunday so bye
everyone
thanks for watching have a good day or
good nights oh yes